- So what did you mean,
I saw that you recently said you thought
the world had retired you.
- Well, I think, you know,
this is not a business that is
particularly kind to aging.
And I was blowin' along,
just doin' one show after
the other for a long time.
And then all of a sudden,
I just kinda couldn't get arrested.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
I hear that from a lotta
women more than men.
- Well, yeah.
- Yeah, it's like crazy.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I do get upset, though,
'cause I feel like men,
they get the salty gray hair look
and it's like, oh sexy.
And then women, and it's like, mm.
(audience laughs)
- Not so much.
- Like it didn't work as well,
but yeah.
- I went gray for awhile.
I was like, "I'm not
dyin' my hair anymore.
"I'm not gonna do it."
- But I actually love
you gray in the show.
- But you know, I got a lotta blowback.
It was like, really?
You wanted this?
- [Kelly] Really?
- Yes, I did.
- Oh, your name is Meemaw.
(audience laughs)
- I know, but that's a wig.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I love it.
It's like, I love it.
It's very Emmylou as well.
- Yes.
- Emmylou Harris, yeah.
- I was just listenin'
to her new album today.
- I love her.
- 80 and unbelievable.
- Unbelievable, I can't even
believe I've heard her live.
I feel like blessed, but let's
talk "Ghostbusters" as well.
So what's the new film?
How's it going, is it good?
- It, well, I haven't seen anything yet.
But we have completed it,
and I think it's gonna be pretty,
- I'm excited.
- Fabulous.
(audience applauds)
- I mean, it's just
another thing we all grew up with.
I love it.
Everything you touch is golden.
I don't know why you have
a problem or had a problem.
- I have been awfully lucky.
- You, I feel the same way.
Blessed, super blessed.
It's nice to know that,
and you know that you're blessed, too.
- Yeah.
- It's cool, it's grounding.